اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى فقرتنا الفنيه
لابرز الاعمال الدراميه على منصه شاهد
والتي نستضيف فيها يوسف زين الدين من فريق
شاهد اهلا وسهلا فيك يوسف اهلا يا لميس
يوسف من ابرز هذه الاعمال رح نحكي عنها
اليوم هو فيلم السكر الذي يعد اول تجربه
ميوزك من اعمال المنصه الاصليه وهو ماخوذ
على روايه الكاتبه الامريكيه جين ويستر
بنتابع الكريب وبنرجع نحكي عنه
[موسيقى]
الان
ليس به ابوان
ليسوا
ساعه
[تصفيق]
اذا يوسف نجاح باهر حققته هاي تحديدا هذا
العمل بنسخ اخرى هل تعتقد انه هذا العمل
الموسيقي بالنسخه العربيه رح يقدر ينافس
هاي الاعمال ويكون بنفس المستوى وشو اللي
بخليه من اضخم الاعمال من نوعه انا اقدر
اقول لك انه فعلا رح يقدر انه ينافس اول
شيء احنا راح نشوف نفس القصه ولكن بطابع
العربي تبعنا ر عم نشوف احنا حتى من
الكليب اللي طلع احنا لسه كمان لسه في
كليبات جايه رح يشوفوها اكيد المشاهدين
راح يشوفوها ضخامه هذا العمل بس ولكن عم
نشوف الروح تبعته قد ايه حلوه عم نشوف
الكاستل مشارك فيه من ممثلين كمان
هي ببطورته راح تكون الاغاني اللي رح
تعملها بصوتها كمان يعني اغلب يمكن نحضرهم
يا صاحب الظل الطويل انا بقول لك اكيد
وحالة يعني كتير قريبه من الجمهور فالناس
هيحبوها كمان ستقدم المنصه لمتابعيها عرض
الجزء الرابع من مسلسل اللعبه بعد النجاح
الكبير الذي حقق اله العمل في اجزائه
السابقه وتابع الكليب
اعرف انت بتلعبي مين انا وسيم احرف لو مش
عارفه تلعبينا نجيب حد ثاني يلاعبنا
[موسيقى]
يبقى توكلنا على الله وكله على قديمه
والعركه ابتدت احنا بنهري على الفاضي
انا شخصيا من محبي هذا العمل المتابعين بس
جزء رابع يعني هل تعتقد انه الناس رح
تضلها مكمله عن الجزء الرابع بنفس الشغف
اللي كانت تابع فيه الاجزاء الثلاثه
الاولى خصوصا انه عم يطرح نفس الفكره
تقريبا نفس القصه شوفي الناس اللي بتتعلق
بمعامل معين تقدر تكمل معه اللعبه الحلو
فيه انه فكره التحديات والالعاب المتنوعه
دائما بتخلي انه المشاهد يعرف شو الجديد
والحلو السنه كمان احكي لك بالجزء الرابع
وجود ضيوف شرف كتيره فانه الناس مثلا يعني
عندي كريم عبد الغفور
اكيد عنهم في المرات الجاي بس خلص يعني
بنى قاعده جماهيريه اللعبه وانا اقول لك
انه الجميع متحمس له من وقت ما اعلنا عن
انطلاقه طيب في شيء كتير مهم هو استانفت
منصه شاهد عرض مسلسل الثمن وذلك بعد توقف
عرضه خلال شهر رمضان بنتابع الكليب وبنرجع
[موسيقى]
شو عم بيصير في مندوبين من الوزاره اجوا
كرمال المجمع السقفي
والان الى اخبار الاقتصاد مع فاطمه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات